tajikistan is deploying thousands of
reserve soldiers to protect its border
with afghanistan where the taliban has
been fast capturing more territory
they've doubled the number of districts
they've controlled since may
that's when u.s forces started their
final withdrawal which is now 90 percent
complete and over the past day they've
consolidated gains in the northeast
the government in kabul has vowed the
areas recently seized by the taliban
will soon be retaken in a
counter-offensive andrew chappelle
reports
on the ground taliban fighters have been
taking one district after another
they now control afghanistan's northern
border with tajikistan
the afghan government says a
counter-offensive is on the way and will
include
soldiers who fled from the border this
week
the afghan people expected that after
the withdrawal of american forces in
other countries
there would be no excuse for the taliban
to continue the war
and they should cease and resolve their
problem through negotiations and peace
but unfortunately you see that instead
they started an undeclared war
and intensified it in the skies the
afghan air force is hitting back
carrying out airstrikes on taliban
gatherings it may not have the latest
equipment
but the afghan air force is trained and
capable its attack helicopters and
planes are equipped with laser-guided
bombs
you know if we compare ourselves with
the american
it's a big difference the new afghan
commander of bagram air base knows they
may not have as much firepower
but he says they're ready for what comes
everybody knows we are living in a
country which four decades
four is continuing so in this case uh
some sometimes we go forward some
sometimes
we sit back this is war
in a combat everything is possible
and nothing is stable for the
internationally backed government to
retake northern areas and keep its
capital secure
it must hold on to bagram the americans
left the base last week
but there's a prison at the site holding
5 000 taliban fighters
rafaela a private in the afghan national
army believes an attack is coming to
free them
we haven't come here to sleep everybody
here is prepared to secure bagram
a morale is high but morale may not be
high for long with the taliban
intensifying its attack
it's really the taliban having leverage
having the upper hand
and i think there's a snowballing effect
once you start seeing that in various
provinces throughout the country
it can become very hard to reverse
particularly with now let's not forget
without robust us military backing and
support
you know it's in the interest of the
united states uh it's in the interest of
countries in the region to ensure that
the afghan government does not collapse
but we're heading to a pretty dark place
at the moment
the pentagon says the u.s withdrawal
should be finished in august
a lot can happen on the battlefield
between now and then
andrew chappelle al jazeera